on this friday night
beloved actor christopher plummer dead
at 91.
[Music]
the world mourns a charismatic canadian
legend who impressed audiences from the
stage and screen
curbing the spread of dangerous variants
how even tougher travel measures could
be waiting in the wings
a black man wrongfully accused of
attempted murder and the calls for an
investigation
and drafted from the icu i still can't
believe this is happening
the nurse who will kick off this year's
super bowl
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with a tribute to a canadian
acting legend
christopher plummer has died at the age
of 91. in our top story tonight
mike draulie looks back at the
extraordinary career of a world-renowned
actor who never forgot his roots
it's hard to remember a time when
christopher plummer wasn't famous
at 24 he was a broadway star even if the
play he was in
opened and closed on the same night to
work mine ends upon their senses
it was but the beginning of a long love
affair with the stage
where his name would become synonymous
with ontario's stratford festival
of course when hollywood beckoned he
answered the call
kill me and they're yours
and after a few eye-catching roles he
agreed to do a family film that he
publicly derided for the rest of his
life why do you stay at me that way
the sound of music won oscars but
plumber called it sentimental and gooey
and would only refer to it as that movie
perhaps what irked them was the fact
they dubbed over his singing voice
i don't want to talk about it
he did love working opposite julie
andrews it was the character captain von
trapp that left him wanting
he demanded more substance to the role
and worried he'd be remembered for
mediocrity for them were you this
much trouble at the abbey oh
much more sir as the great grandson of
former prime minister john abbott
plummer was born into privilege
he was raised in a montreal suburb where
he honed his skills
as a concert pianist
such talent and while he never lacked
for work he struggled to find great
roles as he got older
then in the late 90s he experienced a
renaissance of sorts he won a tony award
on broadway
he got rave reviews for the insider and
in the film beginners he played a man
who came out as openly gay in his 70s
for which he would become the oldest
person to ever win an oscar at the age
of 82.
you're only two years older than me
darling where have you been all my life
he'd receive another nomination seven
years later and stayed busy until his
death
he never lost this allure he never lost
this
sense of being something very rare and
precious
so everyone wanted to work with
christopher plummer he
he there was no one like him his last
project was the second season of
departure
which will air later this year what are
you trying to say however
at times he had a charm to him and
steven russell who acted with him in new
york and stratford
says plummer was one of the most
generous people he ever met
you never ever forgot that
chris plummer was a human being first
and a star later and even though he
despised being associated with one of
the biggest hits ever produced
christopher plummer is the greatest
actor this country has ever produced
plumber's place in the history of
canadian stage and screen
is set mike relay global news toronto
there are too many tributes to list them
all but here's one more
from one of plumber's most notable
co-stars julie andrews
the world has lost a consummate actor
today and i have lost a cherished friend
i treasure the memories of our work
together and all the humor and fun we
shared
through the years now to the covet 19
pandemic and signs of progress in
canada's fight against the virus
according to the federal public health
agency in the last two weeks the number
of active cases across the country has
dropped
by 30 percent and over the last seven
days
the average number of people in hospital
with covet 19 has dropped by more than
10 percent
at the same time more cases of the
highly contagious new variants are
emerging
to date at least 255 cases have been
confirmed
and as abigail beeman reports the slow
vaccine
rollout isn't helping when their
grandparents
are going to be safe when the vaccines
are going to come
the prime minister acknowledges
everyone's sick of the pandemic but he
wouldn't answer what canada's recourse
is if companies don't deliver vaccines
on time
i speak almost every week with the ceos
of these vaccine companies they have
assured me
that they will meet their obligations
their contractual obligations
to deliver six million doses to
canadians
by the end of march deliveries a little
more information from the procurement
minister
the recourse of course is breach of
contract
but she wouldn't say any more about
confidential vaccine deals other than
all of them are based on
quarterly deliveries friday's questions
about when
vaccinations may end lockdowns or
restrictions were left
unanswered too i'm reluctant to predict
what
a normal life or when that might happen
is
is all about at this point the country's
top doctor says she's monitoring data to
find out including from other countries
right now it's a matter of just watch
the space ottawa is also working on more
travel restrictions
we're working hard to stand up
additional testing requirements
for land travel but no one would say
when the previously announced new rules
mandatory hotel quarantines for
international travelers arriving in
canada by air
come into force we'll be releasing the
details of those
those new measures very shortly
five days 10 days
very shortly the health minister says
the national advisory committee on
immunization will release
updated prioritization guidelines this
month for the next phases of the vaccine
rollout when many more people are
expected to get a shot in the spring and
summer
patty haidu says in the meantime she
expects health canada will approve
more vaccines but no word on exactly
when
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the canadian economy lost more than 200
000 jobs last month largely because of
the pandemic
that pushed the unemployment rate up to
9.4 percent
that's the highest it's been since
august the job losses were concentrated
in the retail and services sectors in
ontario and quebec
both provinces impose strict coven 19
restrictions forcing many businesses to
close
statistics canada says the country is
still 850
000 jobs short of employment levels
recorded in february 2020.
just before the pandemic hit canada
new covet 19 modeling in bc shows that
province is on a downward trajectory
but provincial health officer dr bonnie
henry warns the situation
could change in an instant and extended
restrictions on social gatherings and
events
with no end date in sight whether it's
the super bowl this sunday
lunar new year family day valentine's
day
it's an important opportunity for us to
either allow the virus to spread
or to slow it down even more
the province is ramping up genome
sequencing to monitor how fast new
strains are spreading
28 cases of the variants have been
detected in bc
the resort town of whistler has become
one of bc's coven 19 hot spots
the community recorded 547 cases of the
virus last month
that's more than double the cases
whistler recorded in all of 2020
the majority of infections involve young
adults who live
work and socialize together the federal
government says canada could receive
about half a million doses of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
before the end of march the shipment is
part of the global kovacs initiative and
depends on regulatory approval in canada
which could happen next week some
countries are imposing age restrictions
on that vaccine
even though new data shows it's safe our
europe bureau chief crystal german singh
explains
the fog around vaccine safety is
starting to lift as more people
are inoculated my grandparents have had
it now hopefully my parents will soon my
parents actually had their vaccine this
week which is amazing news really
amazing they're 75 and 76
so i think we're doing a great job in
terms of getting it out there
and can't wait to get mine in the month
that followed that very first
jab seven million shots were given with
22
820 reports of side effects nearly all
were what regulators call minor and
short-lasting
issues such as headaches chills and sore
arms the majority of the shots given
during that time were the pfizer
biontech vaccine
but astrazeneca was in the mix
and that shot was drawing a lot of
attention
spain has opted not to give the
astrazeneca vaccine to those over the
age of 65.
age restrictions or cautions have also
been issued by other officials including
those in belgium
france germany poland and italy
just like britain's regulator the
european medicines agency
granted astrazeneca approval for
everyone over the age of 18.
still some nations are concerned because
only six percent of trial participants
were over the age of 65. dr samir sinha
says the vaccines on the market
all offer protection people will be
supported
you know to make sure that they're
getting the best possible vaccine that's
available
and that would work best for them the
astrazeneca vaccine
has an overall efficacy around 62
percent
and there's no suggestion of a lack of
protection
for older individuals a study is
underway in the uk
involving 2 000 people over the age of
55
and results are expected soon crystal
gamansen global news
london demands for an independent
investigation are growing
tonight after a black man was held in a
montreal jail for six nights
before all charges were dropped mamadi
farah kamara
a 31 year old phd student was pulled
over during a routine traffic stop
he was charged with attempted murder
accused of disarming and
injuring a police officer today the
prime minister was asked if he thought
this was an example of systemic racism
and if an independent inquiry should
take place
i know the responsible authorities are
uh very aware of the pressure that will
be on them
to figure out exactly what went wrong
and to fully
answer the questions of friends and
family and citizens
who are extremely worried about this
troubling incident
montreal's police chief insists kamara's
arrest was not a case of racial
discrimination
but based on the evidence investigators
had at the time
another person at the scene is now the
focus of the investigation
global news has learned the dutch man
accused of extorting a bc teenager
online
has been extradited to canada to face
charges
lawyers for aiden coban confirmed the 42
year old was transferred to bc
in december he's accused of tormenting
amanda todd before the 15-year-old took
her own life in october 2012.
the case sparked an international
conversation about
cyber bullying the rideau hall intruder
faces a judge coming up how he answered
to the numerous charges against him
the men who stormed the gates of rideau
hall last summer has pleaded guilty to
eight charges
corey huron a military reservist
appeared in court today
he was originally facing 21 weapons
charges
and one of threatening the prime
minister on july 2nd he rammed his
pickup truck through a gate at rideau
hall and headed for trudeau's home
police were able to arrest her and
peacefully he will be sentenced
later this month canadian fashion mogul
peter nygaard has been denied bail the
judge is concerned about his history of
not showing up to court
and allegations he is getting employees
to tamper with evidence
nygaard who's been in jail since
december appeared via video link in a
winnipeg courtroom today
the 79 year old is accused of sexually
assaulting dozens of women
over a 25-year period he faces possible
extradition to the u.s on charges of sex
trafficking and racketeering for the
first time the prime minister
is responding to questions about
allegations involving canada's former
top soldier
two investigations are now underway
after global news reported
general jonathan vance allegedly had an
ongoing relationship with a woman
he significantly outranked and that he
made a sexual comment to a second
much younger soldier as our chief
political correspondent david aiken
reports
trudeau insists the process put in place
to address those allegations
will be followed one of the hallmark
initiatives of jonathan vance's tenure
as canada's chief of the defense staff
was rooting out sexual misconduct in the
canadian forces
it was an initiative that neatly
dovetailed with prime minister justin
trudeau's focus on women
and gender equality but now with vance
facing his own allegations of sexual
misconduct
trudeau expects the processes vance
himself helped put in place
will be followed we take all of these
allegations or any allegations around
misconduct
or harassment extremely seriously which
is why
we've strengthened the processes in
place in government and
every step of the way we follow those
processes to the letter
that process includes an independent
examination
and an investigation by the military
and those military investigators will
have the authority to go where they wish
says this military lawyer the canadian
forces national investigation service
and to an extent the military police
writ large
have a degree of independence and it's
particularly
investigative independence but
regardless of the military investigation
there will be lingering
political questions particularly since
sources have told global news
that the military ombudsman flagged some
issues about vance
to trudeau's top advisors in 2018. this
doesn't stop with general vance
what people are going to be just as
concerned about is
what the various governmental decision
makers knew
when they knew it and why they did or
did not take certain action
trudeau friday seemed to say his
government has acted
appropriately from the very beginning
this government has made it very very
clear that
everyone in this country particularly
working for the government particularly
working for the canadian armed forces
deserves a safe and secure work
environment free
from any harassment as for vance he
denies the allegations
that he ever acted inappropriately
towards female subordinates
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
still ahead wuhan's rebound how the
region is now profiting
from the pandemic
exactly one year ago the city of wuhan
china was
under an unprecedented lockdown to
contain a mysterious new virus
as jeff semple explains life in the
epicenter of the kova 19 pandemic
has largely returned to normal
lately bin zhao has been feeling
homesick the calgary father grew up in
wuhan china
he was visiting his parents there last
year when the city became ground
zero for kovid 19. it was scary
i've never seen the city
like that ottawa even sent a plane to
rescue canadians trapped inside
including zhang's family i was happier
than winning a lottery
but one year later that pandemic script
has flipped
wuhan is roaring back to life back to
school and work
still wearing masks but breathing easier
knowing there hasn't been a confirmed
case of covid19
since last spring zhang even considered
taking his family back to wuhan
because you know be safer for our kids
safer for us
china's economy is also recovering
driven by manufacturing and an
unprecedented demand
for ppe 95 of canada's imported face
masks last year came from china
even while some local manufacturers sat
on the sidelines
when the pandemic's first wave crashed
into canada this bc based manufacturer
pivoted to produce
medical masks we're getting contacts
from all sorts of different people
requesting different having different
types of ppe the company president mark
rose says after six months
their masks remain in the warehouse
caught in red tape
the u.s government agency that certifies
n95 masks
is dealing with a backlog and without
that certification
rose says they've struggled to sell to
local health authorities
our products are collecting dust on the
shelves we just can't get these to
market
and and the government seems to be
buying materials from
other markets other markets like china
last year canada bought one and a half
billion dollars worth of chinese face
masks
millions of which were later recalled
over safety concerns
but those pandemic purchases helped to
fuel a record-breaking trade surplus for
china
the only major economy that actually
grew last year
the country where the pandemic appears
to have started is now profiting
from it jeff semple global news toronto
up next from the front line to the yard
line the super nurse drafted by the nfl
the weekend will be blinded by the super
bowl lights on sunday
the toronto born singer will be the
first canadian to perform at the
halftime show in nearly two decades
in 2003 shania twain opened the highly
anticipated event with
man i feel like a woman when the tampa
bay buccaneers battle kansas city in
sunday's big game about a third of the
crowd will be health care workers
the nfl has invited over 7 000 doctors
and nurses to the super bowl
as a reward for putting their lives on
the line during this pandemic
and as mike armstrong explains one nurse
will receive a special honor
right before kickoff it isn't that
you'll have a good seat for the big game
i still can't believe this is happening
nurse susie dorner's actually going to
be
on the field at least at the beginning
would you please toss the point
when the team captains take part in this
year's coin toss dorner will be
one of them we are extremely grateful
she was surprised last week
working from home buccaneers hall of
famer derek brooks turned up in a zoom
meeting
inviting dorner to be an honorary
captain oh my gosh
thank you so much i'm i'm so humbled
and honored i'm speechless
now as tampa general hospital has fought
the pandemic the
opportunities to smile have been hard to
come by
dorner is a covet icu nurse manager
there have been days and weeks that were
like a nightmare
this was a video put out in november the
past five months have
definitely taken a toll on my entire
team
is physically and emotionally exhausting
now the work dorner's done here at tampa
general hospital
isn't her whole story unfortunately
in the middle of all this she lost both
her grandmothers
it was natural causes not covid but one
of the grandmothers was a nurse in the
second world war
she was the inspiration that led dorner
into nursing
well losing her during covid was also a
lesson
i wasn't able to be there when she
passed away i wasn't able to say my
goodbyes so
one thing that i really pushed after she
passed away was
i got technology i got more ipads
knowing what she missed
dorner now tries to make sure patients
have what they need to talk to loved
ones
whether it's face timing or zooming to
just keep in touch
or at the end of life as happens too
often
i think there's hope on the horizon with
the vaccine dorner says she's starting
to see the light
at the end of the tunnel but what's
gotten her this far through the darkness
has something to do with football it's
her team
she says well the super bowl's also
given them all some smiles this week and
a welcome distraction as her teammates
help her practice
flipping coins mike armstrong global
news
tampa and that is global national for
this friday night i'm robin gill
tonight we leave you with more moments
from christopher plummer's remarkable
life
the canadian actor may have gone on to
hollywood but he spent half a century
with the stratfor shakespeare festival
he was indeed a legend thank you for
watching
i'll see you back here tomorrow good
night
you